we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p many people really liking the
interview yesterday with pro Trump
libertarian Wayne Allyn root here's just
one voicemail about that interview hey
David just saw your interview with Ruth
oh great one of the best back and forth
session one the best offenses from
anyone in the news and I've been
watching a lot of news now so I'm just
wanted to say thanks and keep up the
awesome shows I enjoyed it I mean it was
definitely an interesting interview the
guy had no real good argument to make
and the audience really liked that
interview we should just do more of that
type of thing even though you disagreed
with Wayne Allyn root did this cause
some liberal commentators and hosts to
go after you in the same way that they
did with Richard Spencer's oh that I
never should have even given him a voice
because he's so deplorable not really
not really no didn't see that on the
bonus show today a Nigerian man with 86
wives who we've talked about before has
passed away transgender boys are now
allowed to join the both Boy Scouts of
America we will discuss why any
transgender boy would ever want to join
the Boy Scouts of America in spite of
the new rule and much more david
pakman.com slash membership get yourself
instant access to the bonus show it's a
whole other show that we do every day
for our paid members and you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 to get a huge
discount off of your membership